foreign
I had what I call a powerful first
experience at 31 years old I made my
first snow angel now that may not sound
powerful to some of you but for me it
was and so how do you get from New York
City to Montana well you have to have a
horse I don't make the rules but not
having a horse is why so many people
don't make it out there I'm kidding I
was actually invited to attend and speak
at a conference in Big Sky I'm a kid
from the Bronx so I knew nothing about
Big Sky I knew nothing about Montana in
fact I had only recognized images
similar to it as the screensaver that
comes on whenever my MacBook goes idle I
landed in Bozeman and the first thing I
did was thank God because I don't like
flying even though I have to do it often
I walked out of the airport and I saw no
skyscrapers no lines of cabs no people
yelling and arguing and there were no
funny smells that I was familiar with
you know all the things that make NYC
amazing so fast forward I'm in the
passage you see the car and I'm looking
out the window and I'm just taking on
the views mountains covered in snow
trees everywhere and at one point we
passed by these homes that had to be
worth millions of dollars because they
had the most beautiful view of the
environment later the next day as I'm
getting off stage from speaking a woman
comes up to me and she asks would you
like to go on a hike now I'm from New
York city so a hike is a few city blocks
New York City is at sea level so we're
talking about real oxygen so no this was
a hike and at 8 000 feet elevation one
quickly realizes Montana's oxygen just
isn't real
Midway through our hike I can't remember
what I said but the woman grabs A
Fistful of snow puts it in her mouth and
she starts to chew and my initial
thought was that was disgusting I would
never touch anything that touches a New
York City street but then I realized
this was Snow from Montana and this was
symbolic of the relationships montanans
have with their environment so towards
the end of the hike
this woman lays down in a bed of snow
and she moves her body in a way where it
registers to me
she's making a snow angel
so after about 30 seconds I decide to
mimic and so I lay in his fresh bed of
snow in Montana I move my arms and my
legs and then it Dawns on me
I'm making the snow angel for the first
time
and of course I've seen other people do
it and I've seen it on television before
but it was the first time I did it you
see I've coined the term powerful first
experiences or pfes as doing something
you never thought you would do for the
first time and a place that you never
thought you would be in for the first
time the main reason why I was in
Montana in the first place was to give a
talk about powerful first experiences so
it's only right that I would then have
powerful first experiences in Montana
powerful first experiences a
life-altering moments and experiences
that change the way that we see
ourselves and changes the way we see the
world
and they can be as expansive as
skydiving out of a plane in France or as
small as visiting a lake to meditate for
the first time what matters is your
imagination your courage and your
curiosity
in the book power of Moments by chip and
Dan Heath the author's reference what
psychologists call the reminiscent bum a
phenomenon where older individuals are
asked to think about their experiences
where they tend to disproportionately
talk about the experiences that happen
roughly between the ages of 15 to 30.
some researchers say this is a time in
our lives we experience the most novelty
and there's a few theories why one when
you enter and pass through your 30s life
can seem like it speeds up because we
develop the habits of doing the same
things over and over
another reason is that there are just
some experiences in our lives that are
said to happen within that time frame so
think about it by 15 you might be in
high school
by 18 you may be in college after
college you get a job you may buy the
big home you may get married you may
have a kid
and then you might experience loss of
grief and then you enter your 30s and
that's it no more powerful first
experiences and life repeats itself over
and over
something about that seems so
unfulfilling
now imagine if you're a kid from a
community like the Bronx while the Bronx
offers amazing experiences by the time
you turn 14 to 15 you can feel like
you've experienced all the powerful
first experiences in that environment
and so I became obsessed with figuring
out how to give more powerful first
experiences to others my organization
gentleman's Retreat focuses on young men
of color from the inner city who end up
going to top colleges and universities
such as Brown University
these young men are gifted and they're
special
they just felt they experienced
everything the community had to offer we
call these young men G's for gentlemen
and while working with these gentlemen
and giving them powerful first
experiences
I realized it was shaping their
identities in a positive way
but it was also increasing that cultural
and their social capital
an individual has cultural capital
because of the environment that they
come from
the knowledge skills and belief of that
environment can be seen as capital or an
asset
and having the combination allows an
individual to have economic advantages
and other advantages
and when you collect powerful first
experiences you're collecting cultural
capital from different environments
social capital is a set of shared values
and resources that allows individuals to
come together to achieve a common goal
it can also be thought of as the ability
to access resources and favors and
information from your network
countless connections are fostered when
the gentleman develop intimate
relationships in places such as Paris
London and even Montana
as they spend time with locals
entrepreneurs and even Venture
capitalists
they develop a more expansive Network
and idea of the world and increasing
cultural and Social Capital doesn't just
benefit the gentlemen it also benefits
the communities that they bless with
their presence
and a powerful first experience changes
the way you see yourself and the way you
see the world
going to Big Sky
change the way that I saw the world the
way that I saw myself and what I wanted
to do in the world
instead of waiting for my cycle of
experiences to repeat themselves doing
the same things over and over
I decided to go out into the world and
collect powerful first experiences
and a powerful first experience can be
anything it's all about intention
the most important part of a powerful
first experience of a PFE is intention
anyone can have them you don't have to
have capital or have started an
organization you don't even have to be a
g you just have to be thoughtful about
two things one do something you haven't
done but have always wanted to do and
what's important here no matter what you
choose to do skydiving out of a plane
learning a new language switching your
wardrobe whatever you decide to do has
to have a certain level of risk in it
for you
it's about courage
the courage to get on the plane and go
to a state where most people don't look
like me in order to experience something
as simple as making a snow angel
second thing switch up your environment
change the stimuli and please try to be
bold
so you may be a singer but maybe you
sing on a crowded train in New York City
or in the beautiful streets of Venice
Italy imagine what the world would be
like if we decided to share an exchange
a more powerful first experiences
would we feel more loved will we feel
more connected will we feel more Brave
most importantly
would we feel more human
each and every one of us has so much to
experience if we allow ourselves the
gift of another powerful first
experience
my only ask if you decide to go to
Montana for the first time please don't
forget your horse
thank you
[Applause]